regardez-moi la teste la police alors
comme le volant est là c'est
probablement pour les Anglais mais ça va
venir clignoter en bas donc eux aussi au
cours derrière franchement vous allez
pas vous marrer on va avoir le giron
intérieur alors pas de Giro extérieur
peut-être qu'ils peuvent venir le mettre
mais je trouve ça très marrant alors ça
je le vois sur un salon je savais pas
que Tesla pouvait proposer une
déclinaison pour les forces de l'or
est-ce que vous vous avez une Tesla et
est-ce que vous seriez intéressé par une
Tesla police alors on peut pas l'acheter
bien évidemment mais une fois de plus ça
me fait marrer je trouve ça beau voilà
je partage des petites innovations des
trucs un petit peu rigolo mais c'est
vrai que je vois comme ça là je sais pas
si c'est une idée de mèche ou si c'est
une idée de la police anglaise mais en
tout cas sur le principe je trouve ça
assez marrant